there will be a lot of CrossFitters who
will be listening there will also be
some some power lifters some weight
lifters and some endurance athletes as
well but right I would be interested to
hear if you could give a an explanation
of what are the typical injuries and why
that you see them with CrossFit your
assessment of the injury to methodology
relationship yeah well it's a fabulous
question but injuries cluster around
specific for sports and specific
training methods and there's a reason
for it it's the chronic exposure so
physical exposure to the body causes
adaptations now that up to adaptation
can be good or it can be bad but you
load the body and the body will adapt so
that's the beginning opening principle
if you go back to that tee nation
article I I think it was in the title of
the first paragraph if I have a
love-hate relationship with CrossFit I
mean I absolutely love CrossFit
for the culture for the supportive
community I love it I if I was younger I
would have been in there a hundred
percent but now let's get into the
biological adaptation and then I can
give you a solution so CrossFit combines
adaptations to stimulate mobility and
then the next exercise is asking you to
have a tougher collagen let me give you
an example so if you start out a routine
with ten burpees you are creating a high
mobility in the back without much load
so burpees on their own are probably not
going to create too much challenge to
the adaptation process you're teaching
the spine to be a bit more mobile but it
doesn't pay the price because there's no
load then the next routine is repeated
Olympic lifts now we have a problem
there's no margin for bad form so
CrossFit
[Music]
tries to create an endurable athlete a
power athlete and a mobile athlete
that's very very difficult to do in
terms of biological adaptations so by
programming ten Olympic lifts you know
the form is going to deteriorate
now you're migrating stress the first
two reps might be alright and and
interestingly enough I don't get many
Olympic lifters in as back pain patients
they have to go and see the knee and
shoulder guys those are the joints that
the Olympic lifters are having trouble
with not really that they've got quite
healthy low backs as very stiff well
they lock them into much more of a
neutral position because the mobility is
at the the hips and they're actually a
speed power athlete they're very very
quick they have good pulsing on and off
they they relax to catch the bar and the
snatch and all of these kinds of things
but let's get back to the CrossFit
programming the first two lifts might be
fine the third one now you're starting
to get a little bit tired you're
polluting the perfect movement muscle
memory of an Olympic lifts so do you see
to be a great Olympic lifter you would
never pollute it when you're tired but
CrossFit's a different sport it is an
endurance and look I get the sport you
know there's lots of sports that that
aren't necessarily the best for your
long-term athleticism that's just you
know I have a lot of MMA athletes I I
don't think that's a particularly
healthy thing to do for your body but
it's a sport nonetheless and they come
to me asking for help so of course I
CrossFit athletes as well and it's my
job to try and adapt their body to be
resilient but we have to make a
compromise here but that's the nature of
the programming so somewhere you have to
be between stiffening the spine collagen
through repeated loads
buzzers heavy load exposures but you
can't move your back you know that
that's the difference so on rep 1 & 2
you might be fine on the Olympic lifts
but rep 8 9 and 10 are pretty nice in
terms of the bending stresses and it's
at that point where things fall off the
rails in terms of biological adaptations
and the collagen starts to the fibers
not the fibers necessarily but the
ground substance but between them start
to loosen up and the fact of the matter
is the nucleus will slowly work its way
through the dilemonade in collagen and
get a disc bulge so every sport has its
[Music]
pattern shall we say and that certainly
is now if I could offer this and and I
think in that article I I did offer a
solution at the end and it comes from
let's take the good things from CrossFit
and mitigate the things that are not so
good in terms of biological adaptation
and Dan John if you have you ever heard
of Dan John out of the US they call him
the the quirky uncle or something of
training he's a fabulous fella we're
both the same age we're both in our
middle sixties we we have somewhat of
the same background and whatnot but Dan
is a really wise guy and he's he's very
clever in that he can say magnificent
things in just a few words but Dan's
solution to the Burpee Olympic lifts
routine would be to do kettlebell swings
with a goblet squat for example so there
would be a wonderful substitute in a
CrossFit program to mitigate the
biological adaptations that are going to
lead to tissue breakdown isn't that it
isn't that an interesting one to think
about so from a biological adaptation
point of view both of those involve a
hip
they involve strength endurance and
they're telling the body to adapt in a
consistent way which is not so with
burpees and Olympic lifts anyway there
there's just a thought for you but you
mentioned other athletes as well like
power lifters for example they have a
slightly different cluster of patterns
for back injury but generally speaking
they to begin with end plate fractures
and smalls nodes but here's the
difference
let's take bodybuilding where you train
on Monday to tear down muscle at the
micro-level Tuesday you rebuild the
muscle in the kitchen and in bed in
other words while you're resting and
Wednesday you go again and you repeat
the process power lifters when you
examine and I worked with some of the
grand old women and grand old men of
powerlifting the very successful ones
you the CrossFitters would consider them
under trained because a very heavy
strong power lifter might do heavy
squats on Mondays and and take five days
off in other words they allowed all the
microfracturing at this is at the micro
level now down at the level of the bone
osteons or the bone cells they are
damaged there's no question but is that
damaged a good thing or a bad thing for
a crossfitter it would be a bad thing
because the crossfitter says oh on my
day off I only ran 5k wait a second
that's not a day off that's more
cumulative so it's crazy to keep
stimulating the body to adapt and then
you know you don't take the day off to
allow the adaptation but the power
lifter has a much more wise biological
adaptation schedule they'll do heavy
squats or or say it's a pull from the
from the ground a deadlift for example
and then they take five days
now let's discuss the adaptation of bone
bone is a piezoelectric material and
what that means is when you stress a
bone it builds an electric charge that
electric charge attracts free ions of
calcium and magnesium and it glues it or
chemically bonds it to where the
fracture is or the high stress but it
takes five days for those new ions of
basic bone building material calcium
magnesium and whatnot to scaffold on
before they break it off again what what
is the crossfitter do they train the
next day and they break off the
adaptation that they were trying to
create so do you see the the same micro
damage in a powerlifter is a good thing
it stimulated adaptation but they were
wise enough to let the biology over the
next five days really build substantial
bone strength that's not typically the
way a crossfitter would train it's just
more is better and they don't allow
sufficient adaptation so these are all
very interesting philosophical things to
discuss in terms of creating robustness
to load and better athletic performance
but you know I I get it I get CrossFit I
get why you do it as I said I would have
been there if it was 40 years ago as
well
however I've learned quite a bit about
biology in the meantime and that's why
these the the the training you know it
may not be so much the the poor
exercises sometimes it may just be the
not paying enough attention to the
adaptation schedules of some of these
things and you know that's just pure
programming so any organization could
change their programming and create a
more robust athlete
[Music]